des Harley Davidson des chapeaux de
cow-boy des visiteurs installés sur des
bottes de paille vous n'êtes pas aux
États-Unis mais dans la petite
communauté viennoise de molette les 1000
habitants se sont mis à l'heure
américaine le temps d'une journée à
l'occasion du West Music Festival au
milieu de l'événement une scène géante
ou 5 groupes se sont succédés pendant 12
heures nous notre style est particulier
parce qu'en fait des reprises un petit
peu improbables on fait du ACDC on fait
du stip un Wolf on fait du Patric
Hernandez donc ça surprend un peu les
gens puis on a quand même des gros
standards de country quand même derrière
les fagots qui vont bien du Johnny Cash
du Brico Wayne des grands noms de la
country
en plus des différents groupes présents
sur place pour mettre l'ambiance des
animations était au programme l'une des
plus suivies la compétition de bras de
fer si t'as pas l'habitude tu perds
mais si tu connais pas bah tu perds
voilà ouais c'est dur ouais c'est dur
quelques mètres plus long pouvait
repartir avec un petit souvenir made in
USA des drapeaux ou encore des ceintures
venus d'outre-atlantiques on a à peu
près 280 à 300 modèles de ceinture
ça coûte combien ça coûte 30 € je crois
j'ai vu à peu près ça dépend alors ça
les ceintures varient entre 20 à 80 100
euros autre souvenir à vivre cette fois
un rodéo sur un taureau mécanique Dylan
est resté pendant près de 30 secondes en
équilibre sur la bête
[Musique]
c'est plus dur que que ce qu'on veut
croire ça fait beaucoup travailler les
cuisses et les bras et ouais faut
réussir à bien tenir je pense que j'ai
fait mon sport pour pour la journée là
ça va bien aussi avec l'ambiance globale
du festival un peu à l'américaine donc
c'est vraiment cool au total l'événement
rassemblé plusieurs milliers de
spectateurs à la fin de la journée ils
avaient tous quelque chose en le deux
molette ambiance un peu à part
moi que j'adore personnellement moi je
suis amateur de de country surtout et
voilà on passe un très bon moment avec
des bons musiciens des expositions de
voitures américaines
toutes mes passions sont là réunies le
festival devrait revenir l'année
prochaine sur la route de molette pour
une troisième édition les visiteurs en
redemande